http://www.youtube.com/watch?v=toOaZKUxL00
Mobile App Security - OWASP and Other Ways
to Get Started
Mike: A couple of things I've already talked
about have already come off the OWASP top
ten list for mobile, which is a list that
myself, Jack Lanier, Zack Mannino, and a number
of other people in the application security
community collaborated on to put together
this list of top ten risks for mobile.
Pete: Yea, OWASP is a great organization.
Mike: OWASP.org
Pete: And highly recommended for all the geeks
out there that want to learn more security
in general- application security specifically.
There's projects- one that covers mobile that
you mentioned, that you're involved in.
And a wealth of other resources and information
there.
So I highly recommend that geeks out there
check that out.
Mike: So, one of the things- and it's actually
number two on the OWASP mobile top ten is
to- the number two risk is essentially weak
server side controls.
So, I just consider it a pointer to the original
OWASP top ten for web applications, which
was a widely accepted list of standards- standard
risks and vulnerabilities in web applications.
It's something that other compliance organizations
have taken to- for example, PCI- to be PCI
compliant, you need to be scanned and assessed
by the OWASP top ten list.
So, when we're writing these new mobile applications,
we need to remember that it's not just code
going on the client anymore.
It's potentially a whole new server side infrastructure
and either a SOAP based web service or RESTful
service.
And, these new pieces of technology are ripe
for attack.
It's funny, when the iPad's first came out,
within the first couple of days there was
the first "Pad hack" where all sorts of private
details and data about the initial customers
who received their iPads was made public.
It was essentially publicly available on the
internet.
And the reason for this was, essentially,
poor server side controls.
There was no access control on these web services
that the iPad was communicating with.
So, people could just bypass the iPad, fire
up a web browser, talk directly to the web
service and extract all this data.
And that was labeled as an iPad hack, when
really it's kind of the same thing we've been
dealing with for well over a decade now.
SQL injection, info validation attacks, improper
authorization, lack of access control.
Pete: So, if I'm not starting from scratch-
what if I'm a developer and I already have
a mobile application out and maybe I didn't
think through some of these architectural
or sensitive data storage on the- maybe I
didn't think through all those issues when
I was originally architecting my app.
What's the first thing I should do to try
to secure an existing mobile application?
Mike: Sure.
I would perform a code review for security,
where someone looks at the code, line by line,
manually, and assesses that code based on
the current OWASP top ten risks for mobile
apps.
Pete: So, I could do this myself as a developer,
it's not necessary to hire and expensive security
consultant.
I could go to the OWASP and search or work
my way through the top ten and do a code review
of my own application for that.
Mike: Certainly.
I mean, something as simple as data storage
on the device- you know if you're storing
sensitive data on the SD card.
If you see yourself doing that, that's bad
because that's basically a public location
on the device and the application could access
it.
So, yea, I think it's certainly doable for
a developer to start working through these
risks and analyzing their own code.
Pete: How can the geeks reach out to you if
they have questions about application security?
Mike: Sure.
Well, you can always just Google me, Mike
Zusman, and a number of things will pop up.
My blog will pop up.
You can also find me on Twitter.
My handle is @schmoilito, which is not as
easily spelled.
Pete: I think I always forget that last I.
And, the name of your company is Carve Systems?
Mike: Carve Systems, yes.
Pete: Great.
Awesome.
Well, thanks for chatting.
Mike: Yea, thanks, Pete.
Pete: Security's a great topic.
It's something I want to cover more, like
I said, in future episodes.
So, maybe we'll bring you back and do a deeper
dive into something OAuth related perhaps.
Mike: Sure, definitely.
Thanks for having me.